so this is me and my family my wife
Carrie and our four children three years
ago we started growing our own food and
this is what our backyard looked like
when we started and this is what it
looked like a couple years later and
through this process I learned a lot and
I had to memorize a lot and there are a
lot of calculations I did makin a lot of
things I had to do and all while I was
doing it I was thinking software would
make this so much easier software to
make this so much easier I've worked in
software since I stepped out of high
school essentially and it's it's all
I've ever known and back then I started
thinking about the app I would like to
build but I did not have the coding
skills at that time to do so
I've worked primarily in test automation
or Quality Assurance throughout my
career I've done some work of product
management things like that but I've
never done the type of coding it
required to build something like I
wanted to build so last year at the
encouragement of my team and I'll get
more into that here in a minute I
started working on building my first
mobile app and as chase mentioned this
is the app that that we released I say
we because my wife and I worked on
together I'll talk a bit about that as
well but this is the app that we
released just last month so this app
helps people grow food it will guide you
through growing over 40 different
vegetables and managing over 30
different pests in the garden and this
is just the first version of the app
what I'm working on now is doing things
like telling people when they need a
water based on how much it's rained
around them and when they need to plant
things based on where they are and their
weather conditions things like that so
that's where I'm wanting to go with this
app but I don't want to get too much
into the app today I'm really here to
talk about how I learned to code because
I've had a lot of people ask me how I
did it and that's really what I'm here
to share today so I'm gonna start off by
kind of outlining the five steps here so
so the first one is to get inspired for
me I went back to the garden I had an
app I wanted to build I had a goal in
mind that was the passion that drove me
to learn how to code in the past when I
had tried to learn I had failed because
it was a college course from building a
calculator I just didn't care about it
it took me having something I cared
about in order for me to do the steps I
needed to do in order to to learn so
step number two was find a mentor in the
past whenever I tried to learn it's
pretty overwhelming
landscape when you walked into it
there's all these frameworks and all
these terms and all these things you've
got to learn it's overwhelming if you
have a mentor they're gonna help guide
you through that process learning
foundational principles that's another
important part and I'm gonna go ahead
and go into details into each of these
now so with a mentor what they're gonna
do is they're gonna help guide your path
as I mentioned there's a lot of
different things out there when I first
stepped into this you know even just
when I started thinking about building a
mobile app I did not know where to start
whether it was xamarin or if I needed to
learn Android development or iOS
development or react native or all these
different things out there right so the
mentor helped guide me a chase helped
guide me along on that they're also
going to be there to answer your
questions so if you run into problems
you're not just I still go to stack
overflow a lot but but if if I have
uncertainty about something or if there
isn't a clear defined answer I know I
have someone that I can go to that knows
what they're talking about and is going
to give me a good answer they're also
gonna be aware of the Year code so if I
make a mistake along the way he's gonna
be there to let me know hey this may
work but there's a better way you could
do it or just you never know what you're
gonna learn along the way and then also
to encourage I mean I failed at
programming when I first started trying
to learn back 10 years ago in college
and that stuck with me I there's not a
lot of things I've failed at in my life
I don't say that boastful it's just yeah
so I felt it that and it stuck with me
and it was in the back of my mind and
the reason why I hadn't started trying
to learn to code before then or before
last year was because I wanted to wait
until I had all the time to do it and
and what I learned was that just wasn't
gonna happen until I made it and chase
being there to encourage me along the
way went a long way towards keeping me
focused on that goal and making me feel
like I was on the right path so learning
the foundation of principles was an
important first step because you've got
to know the language you've got to know
what you're looking at in order to began
I had done a lot of college you know
I've done some college courses in the
past and I've done some tinkering you
know throughout my life so I had had
some foundation there I knew what
variables were I knew what loops were
things like that but still I needed to
get better at it so I used code school
comm and other websites like that at the
beginning just to get familiar with some
of the concepts and just get coding
again just get my fingers you
doing it plural site was also a huge
help I watched so many purl side videos
also YouTube though you don't have to
pay for content west boss has a great
series called JavaScript 30 where you do
30 different JavaScript challenges that
are pretty simple or you know there's
basic little things and he guides you
through it and you learn a lot along the
way also fun fun function is one of my
favorite YouTube channels and it really
deals with more high-level concepts he
doesn't really do tutorials as much it's
more just high-level programming
concepts but there's all sorts of
channels out there and these are just a
couple but there's there's thousands of
channels out there that could help you
the next step for me was to find a
framework because I wanted to build a
mobile app and I didn't I they're
talking to chase and some of my other
co-workers I had landed on ionic as kind
of what I wanted to to start with so
once I once I discovered that I went to
lay on it homepage and they have really
good tutorials there that walk you
through building simple apps they have
other amped apps so you can basically
clone and you can start to dissect and
figure out how they work and that's how
I started learning I just started taking
apart example apps and changing things
and seeing what happened when I changed
it and then learning from there once I
discovered that it was angular it was
ionic I need to learn I need to learn
angular first cuz that's kind of the
technology that drives it and or that's
the language behind it I guess I should
say so I turned the poro site Debora
Kurata and John Papa have amazing
courses on Perl site that walk you
through building an angular app from the
very beginning all the way through to
the end
those were invaluable as well and again
on the free side there's plenty of
YouTube tutorials level up Tut's and
then here's a couple other that I
mentioned that are specific to mobile
and ionic these are the people that I
learned from and then once you do that
once you start to okay so then another
another thing is it Tecla home events
things just like this Aaron I've
listened to you speak you know I learned
a lot from you there's other people in
this room that I've learned from also if
you don't have a mentor already it's a
great place to meet a mentor I've met
several friends through this
organization that have helped me and
taught me things and have introduced me
to people and it's been invaluable so
other ways to learn because I learned a
long time ago that if I stare at a
computer
for 20 hours a day my head is gonna go
crazy that's what led to me into the
garden to begin with that's why I
started garden that's because I've been
on this mission to figure out how to
help with anxiety and depression because
when I stared a computer too much that
flares up so I didn't want to go down
that path again I did a little bit
omitted I stared a computer a lot they
were there are days I doubt for 20 hours
but I tried to minimize that and to do
that I use things like podcasts so if
I'm out in the garden I would listen to
podcast syntax is my favorite dad chat
has a great a lot of great ones as well
but I'd be out in the garden working and
I would still be learning about
development I just wouldn't be staring
at a computer while I'm doing also
Twitter so every one that I've found a
course from so Deborah Parata John Papa
the people I mentioned all throughout
before I would find them on Twitter and
then I would read everything they wrote
and I would follow the people that
retweeted and I just immersed myself in
this so instead of reading the news or
reading you know just Facebook or or
whatnot I would focus that energy on
learning what it is I want to learn and
and through the same mediums that other
people were learning as well so I use
Twitter just not for reading politicians
stuff so I thought it's just reading you
know what software developers were
talking about and what it is they're
interested about and then also that's
gonna point you back to blogs as well so
all these people that put out this
content generally have a blog as well so
you find that and then it's just this
whole ecosystem of continual learning so
if you just immerse yourself in it so
that's that's kind of the practicality
behind how I learned but there's some
other lessons you know around this that
I don't want to talk about so the first
one is that a lot has changed when I
first tried learning coding forever ago
there was a lot of things that were
different than now I know that the
frameworks and then all the new things
make things seem a little overwhelming
and it adds complexity but once you get
through it and you understand why
they're there and what they're there for
you realize things are a lot easier than
they used to be and building this mobile
app all the components were already
built for me I didn't have to build a
grid or a slider or any of those things
I just hooked in what's already built
and it makes it to her I can focus on
the problem I'm trying to solve which is
helping people grow through and not how
to build the best grid
so that's one thing that's changed just
made this a lot easier because I have a
tendency to go down a rabbit hole where
if I can build a grid I'm probably gonna
spend two months on it and go way
overboard or you know go I'm just gonna
I'm gonna get lost I'm gonna lose sight
of what it is I'm trying to do so having
that abstracted out really helped me out
another thing is that the patience is a
virtue that I it took me a long time to
learn and I still have a long way to go
but walking away can be extremely
powerful if you get stuck on a problem
and you just keep hammering away you
can't figure it out just gonna walk away
do something else that uses another part
of your brain go watch the dishes go
water you're go just what it whatever it
is that makes it true you don't have to
think about what you're doing that is
the key to figuring out the problem
because you rest that part of your brain
and then when you come back to the
problem usually for me I'll be out in
the garden watering the the solution
will come to me I'll drop the water and
can sprint inside as fast as I can start
typing in the Wawa it worked and that is
something that took me a long time to
learn because in the past I would keep
trying to figure something out I would
get frustrated I would get stressed that
I'm not that I'm gonna can't figure it
out I'll start to think of it I'm stupid
because I can't figure it out and then
that would snowball into negative
thoughts and then nothing productive
would come out of that now I just trust
the fact that okay I'm gonna walk away
from this I don't like that I'm walking
away I'm mad that I'm walking away from
it but I'm going to do it and I'm gonna
go play with my daughter or do something
and then when I come back I know the
answer is gonna be there and it took me
a long time to learn that that lesson
and that's really what patience was for
me don't get stuck this really ties into
that don't be stuck in a problem for
more than thirty minutes to an hour
before you either take a break or reach
out to a mentor I tried to play tough
guy with it in the beginning and I would
hammer through a problem for a day and
then when I got the solution from my
coworker the next day I felt pretty
silly because I could have saved myself
a lot of trouble and they didn't think
any less of me for asking that was
something I had to get over don't obsess
over picking a lame language or a
framework I know I mentioned that you
need to pick one but don't I spent a lot
of time in the past two obsessing over
thinking about what I need to learn or
what framework or what language it
doesn't matter just pick something gets
once you start coding you'll learn what
it is you like or don't like about that
and then you can evolve from there I'm
in ionic now but I wouldn't be surprised
if I switch to react native or something
like that just to get more of a native
feel to my app but I started with ionic
and I'm happy with that and I don't have
any regrets about it so don't don't be
too concerned about getting stuck in the
wrong framework as long as you're making
progress that's the important part
code something every day so I had days
where I felt like if I couldn't code a
whole bunch of stuff I didn't want to
code it all and that wasn't that wasn't
very productive so I try and code a
little bit every day now or even if it's
not on my app just do some sort of
coding every single day because then
that helps then you're repeating those
things that you're learning and then
you're in your you're just getting more
experience with it and then fight
through imposter syndrome you're gonna
feel like you don't know what you're
doing at times and sometimes you don't
know what you're doing but it's okay you
don't have to know everything and it's
okay to not know everything so don't
feel like you're a failure just because
you can't figure something out and then
the last thing is that prior experiences
what were way more valuable than I
realized
when I was a kid I spent all of my time
building websites and trying to figure
out how to make video games work
different and just doing all these
things that all of these skills played
into everything I do today now and I had
no idea that already had all those
skills all the I used to write batch
files do things you know there's all
sorts of things like all the scripting
skills I had have all become valuable to
me now and I discounted how much those
were worth in the past so yes I had to
learn a lot of JavaScript but my HTML my
CSS knowledge authority that foundation
was already there and that really helped
me out so lastly I'm gonna leave you
with with this quote and and this was
really the idea that led to me learning
to code and to build a mobile app if
there's a problem that you see in the
world if there's something you'd like to
do you like to see different we live in
an age that is unprecedented for people
like us we have never had the power that
we have today to change the world if you
get an app into the App Store you were
in front of probably billions of people
now I don't have millions I've been a
lot of people and all it takes is
one app that can change the world my
hope is that my app can help people grow
through whatever your passion it is
start putting time into building that
because like I said we've never happened
I had an opportunity like we have now to
make an impact on the world we've been
given all of these these blessings and
these skills and these talents and for
me I feel like if I don't do something
with them and if I don't make an impact
on the world with them then what am I
doing here
that's that's the way I look at so
anyway are there any questions you have
here's my contact information if you one
has any questions about anything